[Musique]
tu t'assois mais c'est simon doubt votre
professeur de violon bonjour est ce que
vous connaissez la musique classique
balmain femme adèle beethoven il a fait
le truc là quand un corps
[Musique]
comment sont avant tout je veux
m'assurer que vous resterez bien que les
enfants jusqu'au concert puisqu'on est à
ce permis de changer de sa folle et on
se remet en place cette année un peu
plus pacifique s'il vous plaît et sera
capable de se concentrer pendant 30
secondes stop stop stop
s'il vous plaît si l'on prend lui
apprendre pas les forcer qu'est ce que
tu fais là et je suis devenu le violon
c'est pourquoi c'est intéressant vélo
oui ça vous des reçus par un élève de
plus tu es motivé oui pourquoi pas oui
j'ai une proposition pour partir en
tournée pendant trois mois quand tu t'es
engagé à les emmener à la philharmonie
tu trouves
pas pris ma décision
[Musique]
les doigts en même temps il est fait
pour la musique
tu vas trop sur la touche
tout donner et rendre vos parents fiers
de vous
[Musique]
ça s'est bien passé ton concert
en ce moment je travaille avec des
gamins java
je sais que vous en être capable
je compte sur vous d'accord
[Musique]